this is a KGB officer who persecuted
Christians for a living and is a thug
and a murderer I still don't understand
how anyone who has at least a triple
digit IQ can say the Russian Federation
and Putin are the good guys what do you
make of the fact that a lot of people on
your side are celebrating a 21 year old
who is stolen
secret documents and they're calling
this person a whistleblower yeah and
worse than that they're calling him a
hero my fear is
that they are Whispering sweet nothings
in his ears saying you're the kind
you're the guy and he's being exploited
by The Establishment Rhino class do you
think he stands a chance no
no and I'm sorry Ron DeSantis doesn't
have the balls or the maturity to do it
so for me the the reason I am voting for
president Trump is supporting him I need
somebody to come back into the city
and burn the corrupt
[__] to the ground
foreign
[Music]
ometry on the road from the USA I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our fantastic and returning guest
today is an author counterterrorism
expert and of course former deputy
assistant to the president of the United
States Dr Sebastian Gorka welcome to
trigonometry welcome to the Gorka
headquarters oh thank you very much for
having us we've had a couple of great
days doing fun stuff but here we are
doing serious stuff now we've been
friends for a long time we know you well
a lot of our audience do not and one of
the things they won't know about you is
the background of the backstory your
family's history that informs a lot of
your views so tell us Who Who Are You
Seb and what has been your journey
through life uh well my journey through
life is informed by who my parents were
and what they suffered during World War
II and after World War II so my parents
were kids in Hungary in Budapest
suffered under Nazi occupation at the
end of the war and then after the war
ended and communism was imposed my
father was a young college student who
wanted to resist the new regime created
a secret student organization of
Christian students who are patriots
eventually uh
was betrayed by Kim philby one of the
greatest traders of the SEC of that cold
war period one of the Cambridge Apostles
was arrested the age of 20 tortured and
given a life sentence in a communist
jail he served six years two years in a
prison Coal Mine two years in solitary
and then was eventually liberated by the
Freedom Fighters of 1956. he escaped to
the West with a 17 year old daughter of
a fellow prison mate who ended up as his
wife and my mother and they made it to
the UK I was born and raised in the UK
my first language was Hungarian and then
When The War fell
speaking Hungarian having a bit of a
background in National Security because
I served in the British TA in the
intelligence Corps I got a job working
for the first freely elected Hungarian
government in the defense Ministry so I
packed up moved from London to Budapest
spent five years in the in the Hungarian
government met my wife in Europe an
American started doing some work in
counterterrorism for the American
government doing a training course out
of Germany after 9 11 and then one
morning in 2008 literally my wife and I
woke up and said it's time to go we've
done our dues we've tried to help
Hungary get back on track moved to the
U.S ended up as a professor of irregular
War for encounter terrorism for the
Pentagon wrote a book called defeating
Jihad on the ideology of groups like Al
Qaeda and Isis and that propelled me to
the White House to work for president
Trump now I do a daily radio show called
America first three hours of political
commentary and a uh a weekly TV show for
Newsmax called the Gorka reality check
so that that in a very as brief as I can
make it is my trip and my thing is
strategy politics conservativism and
understanding the threats to uh the good
guys in the west well we'll talk about
all of that and when we were on Rogan
last year having come from here actually
I described you as the Trump attack dog
which I think is fair you have a
reputation for that I think that I think
the telegraph called me uh Trump's pit
bull right well that's a great way of
saying it too and we're going to get to
president Trump uh later but actually we
wanted to start by talking to you about
a national security and Foreign Affairs
but B also what is happening within the
conservative movement and the right
around those issues so what have you
made of the way that some people have
responded to Putin's invasion of Ukraine
on your own team
so before I joined the White House
um I was teaching for the Marine Corps
and at the same time I was Moonlighting
as National Security editor for
Breitbart I didn't need the job okay
Bannon saw me speak somewhere invited me
for a chat said will you be my National
Security QC guy and I said I'm not
really interested and I threw out a
stupid number and he said yes and that's
when you go oh crap
so the reason I was in principle
interested in doing that
what 10 years ago was because of the
paucity I saw on the right of serious
discussion on Nash security because back
then you had two options if you if you
are a conservative in America you could
be a a crazy neocon saying let's invade
places and turn them into democracies at
the end of a gun barrel which is lunacy
right The Wolf of it is of the world the
Bush Administration or it could be an
isolationist and say screw everybody we
don't care uh anything beyond the
Pacific in the Atlantic is irrelevant
and they can all go to hell and I
thought you know you can be a little bit
more nuanced than that there is a pallet
of options and the idea that you can
isolate yourself from the rest of the
world after 9 11 or in the Cyber age is
just as stupid as thinking you can turn
Afghanistan into Switzerland so that's
why I did it today 10 years later it is
by magnitude's worse on our side it is
this is perhaps Beyond everything the
left is doing to this country in my
estimate open borders millions of
illegal immigrants fentanyl poisonings
on and on and on the economy for me the
thing that Galls me the most every
single day and I have people on my
Twitter feed you know get in touch with
the radio show who call themselves
conservatives or Republicans
and who say things
like Vladimir Putin is the savior of
Western civilization and a great
Christian and I'm going
you do know you don't have to be a cold
war child like me but you do know this
is a KGB officer who persecuted
Christians for a living and is a thug
and a murderer and people are saying oh
well he's justified in invading Ukraine
because because we provoked him
what what are you talking a nation like
Ukraine which was ranked 22nd in the
world in military power
is threatening a nation-ranked second
that has more than 4 000 nuclear
warheads and you're telling me we
provoked it or Ukraine provoked it so I
am
horrified we had this discussion over
cigars last night I still don't
understand how anyone who has at least a
triple digit IQ can say the Russian
Federation and Putin are the good guys
so we have to answer your question in
brief we have a lot of bloody work to do
to educate people on my team about the
reality of geopolitics today and you
don't have to be a a geek about it like
me just the fact
well let's do that then because the the
interesting thing is that I think as you
say not a lot of people are educated on
either way what is the National Security
interest for this country
in supporting Ukraine so you can answer
that at a very prosaic level that is
intuitive and then you can go to the
geopolitical level the prosequote look
everybody's gone to school okay or
everybody's been a member of a club or
the Boy Scouts or the football team or
what have you everybody knows what a
bully is everybody's seen a bully
operate now when does a bully stop being
an [__] when you break their
knowledge when you bust them in the nose
if you don't stand up if somebody
doesn't stand up to a bully on the
playground or in Eastern Europe the
bully proceeds to continue to bully the
vulnerable
the idea that whatever reason or excuse
is provided a nuclear-tipped nation with
11 time zones can break a taboo that has
been in place since 1945 in Europe which
means you must not aggrandize your
territory through use of force is
dangerous to every decent Nation every
decent person and if you want to go to
the wonkish level do your homework about
Vladimir Putin or any aspect I love the
bio lab stuff oh really the bio Labs was
the reason who's thinking built the bio
labs
the Soviet Union built the bio Labs it
wasn't Condoleezza Rice and George Bush
that built the you know bio Labs so get
a little bit of your factual uh ducks in
order but specifically a little bit of
homework who is Vladimir Putin beyond
the KGB officer a silo Vicki a member of
the nomenclatura's National Security
Enterprise
he's a man who's since becoming
president for 21 years has been giving
speeches about the illegitus mercy of
Ukraine as an independent nation the
illegitimacy of the Baltic states the
illegitimacy of Poland as an independent
nation that all should be subsumed into
the radina into Mother Russia and you
think well those are the states that
border Russia those are the states who
are fully paid up members of NATO so you
think this won't have consequences that
a man who has already proven that he
will keep his promises to use Force to
take territory wants to take Poland the
Baltic State he must be sent a message
you are not permitted to do that and if
you just want to be very pedestrian
about it he's a bully who has to be
given a bloodied nose and said what
would you say to those people who
provide a more nuanced argument and go
look
we have been an antagonistic presence in
that area of the world and Ukraine is a
buffer zone or a buffer nation and it's
rapidly becoming more westernized he
sees this as a threat to Russia and he
sees himself encroached on practically
all sides by pro-western Nations right
encroached by what what is the quality
of that if when I use the language of
moral equivalency and the and the
terminology of the Kremlin propagandists
what is the encroachment it's the
encroachment of Western values of
representative government that's the
problem for Putin the Putin it isn't
we're an Empire
invading Ukraine invading the baltics
invading the I I work my job was to get
hungry into NATO when I worked for the
Hungarian defense Ministry we were
desperate to get back in why did we want
to be a satropy a slave state of a you
know a Western Empire no we wanted to be
part of what a member of a group of
Nations that is part of the West that
has representative government that has
free markets so so again let's translate
into prosaic terms what is NATO what is
the EU they're clubs
nobody's forced to join the EU on that
nobody puts a gun to the prime
minister's head you know of Sweden says
You must join no you have to want to
join and you have to hit certain
membership requirements in NATO's case
it's very very easy you read the 14
points of the Washington treaty it just
says You must have a represented
democratic government and you must uh
contribute to the collective defense of
the club
okay well if Poland wants to join if
Hungary wants to join if Ukraine wants
to join
why does another Nation that's outside
of the club get to have a veto I mean
imagine if what you're into movies right
like me you joined the BFI the British
Film Institute I was a member when I
lived in England what if your neighbor
said you know he's a bookworm and he
thinks he's a Luddite and he thinks that
movies are evil
would you be okay with your neighbor
saying you have no right to join the BFI
voluntarily you say are you on drugs
excuse me no I have a right to join any
association that I can meet the
requirements of so this whole idea that
we're an Empire
how did we gobble up these nations they
applied it was tough for Hungary we we
had to bump up our defense spending we
had to say yeah these are the things we
will contribute within a year to Nato we
will have a training center these these
are things that are voluntary
but another Nation that's outside gets
to stop you that's just nuts so the
obvious can't you know I agree with you
on a lot of this stuff obviously but
they obvious counter argument to this is
if Mexico wanted to join the Warsaw Pact
would America just let that happen
uh that's a cold war context yeah right
so
America would do its downdust to stop
that
but there would be no moral or other
justification for us to invade Mexico to
stop that we would cease to be America
if we said Mexico has decided if there's
a referendum if it's not some kind of
dictatorship if Mexico decided the idea
that what we're going to invade you to
stop you doing something you voluntarily
want to do we might use Force
if what happened in Afghanistan happened
in Mexico what happened in Afghanistan
in the Christmas is 79. the spats now
were deployed went in and assassinated
the Prime Minister and then the tanks
rolled in and said oh Afghanistan is now
part of the you know the broader
Association
friendly Nations right yeah so so you
know it's again what is missing with
these arguments is the moral content
it's the
um obvious fallacy of the Chomsky eye
Michael Moore moral equivalency that you
know the West is just another version of
the east or NATO is just another version
of a Warsaw Pact no it's not when when
you joined the Warsaw Pact
you were told to join the Warsaw back
give you one interesting example what
was one of the biggest problems with
NATO it's a wonky phrase called
interoperability we're all free Nations
and everybody had their own vested
interests and proclivities I'm a gun guy
we had at the height of NATO a dozen
different kinds of assault rifle for
troops right Brits had the FN America
had the uh M16 on the the belgians had
you know fnc why because we chose them
and they've also packed how many types
of gun did you have
and then how many types of uniform think
about this in across NATO everybody had
it was a nightmare we had DPM camo in in
England uh the the the French had their
kind of uniforms across the whole of the
Warsaw Pact you had the massive hats the
big epaulette why because you didn't
choose how to defend yourself you were
told by the friends Academy you were
told by the general staff in Moscow you
will have the t-72 you will have these
uniforms and you will have an AK there's
no moral equivalence there's no
qualitative equivalence to East and West
despite what tromsky and others would
have you believe and so what do you say
to those people who go look where
funneling billions to Ukraine right you
look at what's happening in our inner
cities yeah look what's happening with
you know the the fentanyl crisis look
what's happening with the unemployment
look at the debt how can we possibly
justify this yeah this is like the the
Tucker Carlson wing of the party here
and it's it it's intuitive it's it's a
seductive argument I mean think about
just I did the figures for my TV show
recently if you add up all the combat
deaths by suffered by the United States
since the end of World War II so that's
Korea that's Vietnam that's post 911
Afghanistan that's out golf one in golf
two if you add all of the war Fighters
killed in combat for over 70 years it's
seven it's a hundred and three thousand
combat deaths
last year according to Biden's CDC the
Center for Disease Control in America
according to this regime's CDC 110
000 Americans were killed by overdoses
mostly from fentanyl so you go what more
people more civilians died in 12 months
in America because of open borders then
died in 70 years of combat in Southeast
Asia in Afghanistan so it's it's kind of
like whoa but that's not how politics
works these aren't mute you can't as we
say in America you've got to be able to
walk and chew gum at the same time just
because we have a border crisis doesn't
mean that Ukraine is irrelevant and
doesn't mean that if we don't do
something about it now it won't get
worse what what are we going to do if we
invade the Baltic states I mean we have
an article for Britain the US is an
article 5 commitment to the Baltic
states to Hungary to Poland if they are
invaded by another Nation they are
obliged we are obliged to respond which
during the Cold War meant what nuclear
war
is are we prepared to do that or should
we do something about it now to make
sure it doesn't get to that point from
the beginning of this conflict 14 months
ago I wrote a piece I think it was from
Breitbart or my sub stack
and when I said we must stop this but
not by boots on the ground I don't want
the 82nd Airborne to be deployed to Kiev
and it's Kiev by the way guys okay okay
um I've said from the beginning we must
help them help themselves
and the argument I used to kind of take
the the legs from under conservatives is
say screw Ukraine is oh okay
is 1776 important to you
the Revolutionary War that created
America
oh it is you believe that America should
have split from King George and
uh-huh
what would have happened if Spain
France and Holland
hadn't supported Washington George
Washington
we are sitting now would be part of the
British Commonwealth damn those French
no seriously so you're right so the idea
just to translate it I don't want to
fight for ukrainians because we're not
an Empire but to help them fight for
themselves
is what we should be doing but to your
first point
shoveling plain loads of cash to an
immensely corrupt regime let's look I
think in Europe of course it's Israel
it's done so at the beginning I wrote an
article three things we need to do
number one we need to supply them with
the means they need to protect
themselves mostly ammunition they need
artillery pieces number two equipment
which they can actually use this asinine
thing that we're sending them Abraham's
tanks Abraham tanks have more than a
dozen different types of fluid to run
them
t72 has oil and Diesel right ukrainians
don't know how to use haven't had the
training for f-16s or whatever else we
have stockpiles of Warsaw era Warsaw
packed air stuff in Hungary in Poland
the Czech Republic Slovakia give them
equipment they can use number two and
the third one is provide we are Peerless
America's ISR so our intelligence
surveillance reconnaissance capabilities
our satellites nobody comes close to us
give them the real-time Target data
packs so they can make the Russians
bleed in Ukraine that's what we do but
not pallets of cash not you know
billions of dollars in the space of one
year that's where I that's my nuanced
approach between the isolationists and
the sender 80 second Airborne now Seb
the risk of giving you an aneurysm what
do you make of the fact that a lot of
people on your side are celebrating a 21
year old who is stolen
secret documents and publish them that
is detrimental to the United States and
the Ukraine's interests and they're
calling this person a whistleblower yeah
and worse than that they're calling him
a hero so I saw this uh the day you guys
arrived in the U.S and I tweeted out and
I said do I tweet this because the Flack
I'm going to get from my so I said yes
sorry I'm going to Tweet it I said
Are you seriously we I said we have
quote unquote conservatives who are
calling this Massachusetts
uh National Guard Airmen not only a
whistleblower a hero
well a you should look out for death
official whistleblower because he didn't
give the documents to Matt Gates one of
the most anti-establishment
conservatives on Capitol Hill he didn't
give them to Breitbart News
to publish or he didn't give them to a
committee of Congress to investigate
whistleblower is actually a legal term
in America it comes from The
Whistleblower act you have to actually
go through a formal procedure with the
opposition to get it out right what did
he do it who did he show it to
26 guys on his Discord gamer uh chat
room
he was flexing
to his buddies to look cool it wasn't
about helping responsible government in
America he was trying to show off he was
a punk and people say well but it's good
the truth is out but the motive doesn't
matter sorry the difference between
self-defense and murder motives matter
okay
um we have problems with how this war is
being managed this Administration has no
idea what they're doing when it comes to
geopolitics to quote uh Obama this is
not Apocrypha you can look it up Joe
Biden's former boss never underestimate
Joe's capacity to F things up
and he has demonstrated that for the
last two years
so
um yeah this guy's not a hero he's not a
whistleblower he's less problematic than
I'm going to piss people off Snowden was
or Assange but none of these people are
heroes none of them and it's not because
I'm defending the the Deep State or the
establishment don't get me wrong I I I
have a reputation for aiding the
establishment
but this guy didn't do it to help
anybody he did it to make himself look
cool with his buddies and we now know
that there were foreign Nationals on
that Discord including IP addresses from
Russia
part of any side I know you guys don't
like tribes yeah I've heard that many
times yeah so but you know in the in the
you know in the 90s in the naughties you
know you had the left you know and I
associated with them and they had these
funky ideas and you were just like well
they're progressives they're you know
they are what they are they're going to
have these funky ideas they're right I
mean they're always kind of boring they
always had their own way of looking at
the world and you know conservative and
all the rest of it
but you're not have gone mental
a lot of them left as in god mentioned
the left have gone mental but your boys
have gone to as well what's going on why
why is this happening tell me who who
first because there's a lot of choices
when it comes to Tonto's on my both
sides there's a lot of choices what what
do you find the most
so the
problem with people saying
isolationists and go America first I get
that I understand I may disagree with it
but there is a logic behind their
argument but just things but the the
depths of conspiracy
in Ukraine and saying things like oh you
know this is an example you know the
crisis actors you know zielinski's
wearing combat trousers therefore it's
not a real whatever they're saying yeah
and these are people on the right and
I'm they've become more and more
anti-establishment but not just you can
be anti-establishment but with arguments
that patently don't make sense well we
should have started filming yesterday
because I think we're discussing this
till the wee hours I've actually
developed a new TV show that deals
exclusively with this problem of
conspiracies it's called conspiracy
Chronicles
um
I will I'm not pushing back but my
response would be this is not a
conservative phenomena this is a western
civilization phenomenon well I agree
with that right whether you believe a 14
year old girl can become a man or
whether you think uh as some people on
our side would State president Trump is
still secretly the president and there
are five thousand UNS you know sealed
indictments he's about to deploy to
arrest the Deep state they're all insane
so you have kieranon and you have blue
or not yeah yeah right yeah so so
why do we have that
many reasons I would but the two big one
biggest ones is
the failure of the education system
the primary problem here is critical
thought
that there's there's
clickbaitery and there's online tribes
that you cannot get out of once you're
in because the individuals in them do
not have the barest tool set provided to
them by the schools they went to to have
critical thought let's stay with the the
bio Labs thing right Putin had to invade
because they're about to launch a
biological attack on on Russia from
Ukrainian labs okay so if I have a
modicum of critical thought I'll
punch into a search engine Ukrainian bio
labs and I want to find what the source
of them where did they originate from
and when I found out what they are part
of biopreparate the biggest illegal
chemical and biological weapons Empire
which is created by the Soviet Union
before the ink was dry on the treaty
with Nixon Banning or chemical
environment before the treaty was dry
they were building the biggest illicit
wmd complex in the world with Labs that
were making Anthrax making botulinum
making chemical weapons and they put
them where in the satellite republics
including Ukraine when it all fell apart
uh Christmas Day
1991 which is a great Christmas present
there's Legacy capacities
what did the West do oh
the Soviets have been cheating for 20
years you know what to protect us from
maybe some of this stuff getting into
the wrong hands like oh up terrorists we
should find out what the solves were
doing in these Labs so let's get them a
bit of money and say oh you need a new
microscope you need a new printer we'll
pay for that if you let us come and have
a look what you were developing
illegally for Moscow
now that might take you what 30 minutes
but to say a nation with nuclear weapons
is afraid of Legacy capabilities they
built in those States when they were
captive Nations
it's just it's just stupidity it's rank
ignorance the second part which is the
exact look you actually had a third one
yesterday the second part is
what has the general public learned in
the last
uh let's go from Gulf War one in the
last 32 years about government in the UK
in the US everywhere in the west what do
they learn
they lie more than we even imagined they
lie from dodgy dossiers to Russian
collusion of President Trump
the vast majority of the conventional
wisdom
is being shown to be fallacious and
deliberately so so there has developed
not a skepticism to the establishment's
narrative but a cynicism if the BBC says
it if the White House says it if 10
Downing Street says it the first thing
my reaction should be is it's a lie it's
the opposite of the truth number two
third thing and you pointed this out
social media
social media I mean not only do you have
access to the things you would never
know 30 years ago because somebody held
up an iPhone while you know Jay-Z was
you know doing something she shouldn't
have been doing right or he was doing
you also have what the dopamine outrage
clickbaitery that incentivizes what in
media today
speed not truth I need to be the first
person with that story whether it's real
or not doesn't matter I need to be the
first person so I get the clicks so my
Advertiser is Happy those three things
together are are where are the key
reasons for why today conspiracy
theories are out of control
on left and right yeah but Mike I I'm
going to sort out the right so you guys
can swear I don't think they're gonna
let us know we're not we're not as
popular on the left as we once were said
because you probably established yeah
um but but also people like Tucker as
well yeah so Tucker you have to put it
you have to know a little bit about
American history Tucker is a
revivification of the America First of
your of 80 years ago or if you want to
be a little bit more less you know
problematic because that movement had
had racist overtones uh the buchananite
he's a hardcore Neo Buchanan Like Pat
Buchanan was such an isolationist he
lives not far from here famous concerted
politician around for president he
actually has written books
saying America should never have got
involved in World War II
that that branch of conservativism is
being resuscitated today by you know the
people who like Tucker what I find out
about that is I think you know 100 years
ago that that made a lot more sense but
in the world that you live in now
today's world of dreadliners and
internet it's it's ridiculous yeah uh
and Seb one of the things that I found
interesting is your former boss who
we're going to get on to in a second uh
he argued that the war in Ukraine would
never have happened if he was still in
office and I agree with that as as you
know I was not a massive fan of his but
I agree with that I'm glad you put that
in the past tense because yeah I'm I'm
All Magna yeah we got it absolutely
absolutely no um
but what troubled me about what he said
at the same time was essentially the the
read I got from what he said is I would
have forced Ukraine to give things away
in order to have peace and to me that's
a appeasement 2.0 yeah I I haven't read
that I haven't seen that but it's one of
the most amusing things I I think
everybody wants to know about wherever I
go whatever I want to talk about sooner
or later what's he really like and they
want to know about him and when I get
asked what would president Trump do now
about Ukraine I just laugh I chortle
because it never would have happened I
mean let me give you one example that
nobody talks about
when we were in the White House
we found out that there were 300 Wagner
group guys in Syria now these aren't
independent contractors these work for
the Kremlin right they were you know the
deniable Little Green Men for the
Kremlin
and president Trump found out that they
were destabilizing Syria what did he do
he did something not even Ronald Reagan
or any president since they stormed The
Winter Palace in 1917 did he told the
Secretary of Defense kill them all now
within 48 Hours 300 Wagner group
nurseries were pink missed
Vladimir Putin
didn't even hold a press conference he
so shot himself
that's what the bad guys think of my
former boss where this little came in
North Korea whether it's the mullers
whether it's Isis or whether it's Putin
they fear this man which is good which
is good because he loves America and
he's not a dictator as a left would have
you believe he loves this country
I'm not sure about he would have could
told him to give stuff away and even if
he said that I would say it never would
have happened so it's above or
irrelevant you never look look at the
last 16 years of politics when was was
Georgia and South assetto invaded under
Obama under George W Bush when was
Crimea taken under Obama then there's a
cesura and there's for four years
Putin doesn't do anything
what were those four years oh when we
were in the white house that's weird so
the guy that we are told is the Russian
puppet of Putin
under his tenure
Putin didn't invade anybody
we leave the White House
Biden surrenders in Afghanistan and I
know what happened in the Kremlin the
second 13 of our war Fighters were
murdered by ISIS in Bagram and that last
jet takes off with literally people
hanging on the wheel well thousands of
people dying clinging to our aircraft
Vlad said all right boys get the tanks
ready we're rolling
so it never would have happened under
President Trump and and that's why we
need him back in the White House and how
do you solve this now final question on
Ukraine how does this get resolved
as soon as this man
is re-elected if conservatives can
achieve that
the conflict will stop immediately in
terms of active engagement and president
Trump will engage
and
behind closed doors he will do what he
does the most he will be very
undiplomatic
and he will make it very clear that this
cannot continue
the question is how does Kiev real
respond to that you are far better
versed in that you've been there your
family there I don't know what is
conscionable for Kiev right now and what
isn't are they prepared to write off Don
bass in Crimea or not I can't predict
that but president Trump will he will
deploy the art of the deal in very
undiplomatic terms behind closed doors
and tell Vladimir Putin that it must
stop otherwise there will be all he does
he doesn't go into details so there will
be very serious ramifications for you as
a nation
and Putin will acquiesce will Kiev
acquiesce and under what terms of who
controls which territory
that cannot be predicted
you said uh what if this man is
re-elected yes so let's talk about that
yeah
um
he's way out of DeSantis in the polls
however this is something that when we
got a little tour of the capital the
other day someone said to us DeSantis is
further ahead than Reagan and Nixon
before they announced
so
how good I mean right now it's looking
good for president Trump yes very good
however he's just been indicted on 34
charges yep
does that help him does that hinder him
well it has so far it's given him a bump
he's now the highest he's been in a long
time since since January the sixth Joe
Biden has sunk to the second lowest he's
ever been 42 popularity since he became
president and also I don't know when
this is going to air but but in the week
of the indictment since the indictment
president Trump raised 12 million
dollars as a result of the indictment so
whether it's polling whether it's money
this was giving him a boost the likes of
which you don't get with a TV ad
campaign or a hundred rallies so
um he's doing well whether he wins or
not is a function of one thing
predominantly let's remember this is the
man who received in 2020 more votes than
any incumbent president in history 74
million Americans voted for President
Trump he's this this is a really pecant
fact he's the only president in history
to ever get more votes
in his second election and not to win
which is really weird isn't it not only
that he's a man who was vilified for
four years non-stop by The Establishment
called a racist a misogynist an
islamophobe a white supremacist and
eventually a Nazi despite that coming
out of the tap 24 7 he received 10
million more votes in the second
election in 20 than he did in 16 which
is quite remarkable and more votes from
the black and minority Community than
any Republican since the 60s so the
basic Foundation
the core of his success
demonstrably mathematically is there the
biggest problem is how we run elections
in America when I came here elections
were held on Election Day I was
sometimes traveling and I could request
an absentee ballot in in the state of
Virginia the Commonwealth of Virginia
where I live I would have to prove why I
cannot vote on Election Day I would have
to have you know a note from my boss I
would have to you know I'm sick from a
doctor or my boss needs to be out of the
car I need to be out of the country I
would have to prove before the last
presidential election
the Democrats managed to engineer that
81 million million ballots were sent out
to people unrequested not I'm sick all
right whatever just on block sent out
that would be sitting on the Stoops of
houses in apartment blocks in piles
ballots and that is a recipe for
disaster
that the temptation to distort that and
president Trump warned us and on top of
that we are meant to believe that an
aged individual who is a uh
career politician for 47 years
who clearly has some cognitive issues
received more votes than the first young
charismatic black president
something is problematic here something
doesn't make sense but the question of
will they be able to keep in place in
democrat-controlled States the covid
justification for mail-in ballots and
for where I live in Virginia which is
asinine we have we now have a 45-day
voting period it's on Election Day it's
a month and a half of voting
I mean look the part I'd agree with you
on is the the the fact that you don't
get a result on the same day it doesn't
make any sense to me uh the fact that
you know the voter ID is a controversial
issue makes no sense to me at all well
it does make sense if you want to steal
elections okay on the other hand though
the fact that a president like Joe Biden
who I don't think commands the love of
the people let's put it mildly uh would
get so many votes can be quite readily
explained by the fact that your former
boss is very off-putting to many people
now you you may dislike that fact but
that's counted by the fact that we see
more votes than any incumbent present in
history oh he did and at the same time
you could argue that he provoked a lot
of people to vote for for the
opportunity yeah so
um but what what then if if he didn't
win last time and the Democrats have
been in charge for four years by the
time the next election happened let's
say we'll talk about the center
separately let's say he is the nominee
right what's the route to success well
the route to success is what the
president has said in his recent uh
truth social video posting which a lot
of conservatives have problems problems
with for obvious reasons but we have to
um out
organize the Democrats the Democrats
have an amazing ground game they have
Machinery to collect mailing ballots
they so we could talk about this for
hours before the last election and this
is illegal by State Statute a private
entity
Mark Zuckerberg's uh Foundation dropped
that we know of officially 450 million
dollars to help run elections locally
now what did that mean it meant a
private entity which is not permitted
state governments of Australian
elections was training people to car
it's called harvesting ballots go to
places where mail-in ballots have been
mailed to and collect them and collect
them and bring them to the polling
stations not only that they created a
system of ballot collection drop boxes
where if you didn't couldn't be asked to
mail your vote in or go to the polling
station within five minutes of your home
at a library or whatever there'd be a
big box you could drop it in for weeks
and weeks and weeks
but the problem was they were all in
predominantly Democrat districts so you
made voting easier in Democrat
strongholds and then you have the
national decisions Movie 2 000 mules
where we have obtained the public
footage of the CCTV cameras of people
dropping literally bundles
of balance at 2 or 3 A.M one guy who's
tracked through his cell phone going to
16 different drop boxes in one evening
sorry who's that does he have 300
relatives that who are sick
these are happening in States like
Georgia where you are it is a crime to
deposit somebody else's vote unless
they're a member of your family so what
the president said is
we've just got to be as organized as
they are in those states where these
things are still permitted because we're
a republic of states there are
differences between how elections are
Run state by state what has happened
since 2020 in many states where the
Republicans are in control of the state
legislature they've banned a lot of this
stuff they said no we're going to have a
voting day if you're sick you've got to
have a doctor's note if you're traveling
it's boss has got a certified so we've
got to clean it up to get back to where
we were so it's fair it's transparent
and where we can't clean it up we've got
to out organize the other side that's
what the president Trump has said and
I'm worried because the the RNC which is
the Republican National Congress which
is the The Establishment party of the
Republicans
they're just oxygen thieves I mean
they're just they couldn't organize a
piss up in a brewery and they're not
getting stuff done this is getting
solved at a local level which is good
but it's not enough so we've got a year
and a half to fix it will we I have no
idea do you have a website or do you
plan to have a website because if you do
then easy DNS is a company for you easy
DNS is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
what would you say Seb and look I have a
lot of sympathy for this argument and
and I agree with it
policy wise
there was a lot that I agreed with with
Trump there was there was
you can it's all right look I know
you're on camera but it's okay right now
you can tell everybody you're a
conservative
is your heroine I'm I'm good I'm good
with it come out come out now and
there's a lot of people training
everyone right now listen uh it's an
archaic it's an archaic reference but as
a movie buff you'd like that I think at
the moment people think I'm the Rock
Hudson of the conservative party
I've been in the closet that long
they're waiting for it oh my gosh yeah I
obviously I don't want to be out in
quite like Rock Hudson that was no that
was a little bit uh comfortable yeah
yeah but anyway would a more modern
reference be the Phillips Schofield yeah
yeah yeah yeah apart from yeah you're
gonna be crying on TV before long
exactly all right what's the argument
the argument is
a lot of the policies particularly
geopolitics particularly International
there's a lot of people be like I don't
like umbrella I kind of agree with what
he's doing right
but the divisiveness the language the
tweets is that really what we need in a
country that is more than ever divided
yeah I hear this all the time I I the
first reaction is I have a friend who
runs an amazing website called American
greatness
um Chris boskirk he's a regular on my
show and he said the indictment has
changed the minds of everyone he knows
who had that opinion who said ah Trump
but once he was indicted by Alvin Bragg
on this made-up you know
business record misstatement that was
you know trumped up into a talked up
into a felony they said screw it they're
persecuting this guy and they've come
back into the fold and these aren't
average people Chris is talking about
big donors who who were conservative but
had issues with the Staffing my argument
is the following and it's not pragma
it's not pragmatic it's principle-based
let me just slightly modify what you
just said there is no policy if you're a
conservative there is no Paul if you
love this country forget concern there's
no policy You can disagree with when it
comes to president Trump in the last
four years in macro terms
biggest strongest economy we have ever
had a relatively closed border clamped
down on illegal immigration
revitalization of NATO not just our
military we've finally got the
freeloaders to pay their share after 40
Years of not paying their share then we
had
um
the
um crushing of Isis
Obama had told us Isis is a quote
generational problem we just have to get
used to we came in and we took the
lawyers out of the way of the Green
Berets and the socom and they they five
months later the caliphate was gone so
whether it's National Security Foreign
Affairs immigration the economy oh how
about this one first time in history
we were selling other people energy we
we were self-sufficient for the
lifeblood of an economy and we were
exporting it so we could thumb up noses
at opecne and Russia and everybody else
so when it comes to everything you could
pick whatever your issue is yeah
yeah that's good and then and then
you're going to [__] and moan to me
about Mean Tweets
well slap yourself in the face
really so for you decorum or Style on
social media is more important than a
strong economy a safe Nation a close
border Isis crushed well then you're a
[__] then you're on an adult you're a
child now don't get me wrong you know
this is you know me in the White House
in the Oval Office when I worked with
this man
I went to you know Public School in
England
I did went in the debate Club
stiff upper lip and all that stuff
his style took some getting used to
the language he used
in the Oval Office with me
made me blush a few times
so what
really that's the that's your metric for
who you want to lead the country and I
just say slap yourself in the face and
grow up what's that there are a lot of
people there are a lot of people with
whom that is symmetric I know but hang
on let me finish here
the problem with my argument and this is
where I'm going to Advocate against
myself is that
my buddy Andrew Clavin says
yeah
but you've got to win elections well
that's my point right
um
I don't have a reasonable answer to that
because you're not going to change a 76
year old man's way of behaving you're
not going to Reign him in you're just
not going to write him in
I have a very personal argument for why
I support him and I why I will vote for
him and it's this
the situation in this city
in federal government inside the most
powerful judicial and intelligence
Enterprise the planet has ever seen
meaning the FBI the CIA the NSA the doj
is frightening to me and I do not
become fearful easily
my life changed inexorably when I was on
holiday on the beach as a eight-year-old
kid
I was playing on the sand with my action
man
my dad who's a bear of a man I mean he
was on the national rowing team two
years down that prison Coal Mine loved
physical exercise loved swimming and he
comes out of the ocean
and he walks up to me Towers over me
and I look up at him and I see something
for the first time ever that I hadn't
noticed before on his wrist I saw these
white lines and he was far too young to
have like wrinkles on his wrists so like
an idiot I said hey Dad what's that he
said to me in Hungarian
that's where the secret police bound my
wrists together with wire behind my back
so they could hang me from the ceiling
of the torture chamber
your life that is when you arrive at a
fork in a road and your life diverges
because at that point for me
evil
wasn't you know Saruman from Lord of the
Rings it wasn't Wiley Coyote from a
cartoon from that moment onwards I
understood evil exists it's real it you
know lurks in the heart of men and we
must do everything we can to stop it I
couldn't have expressed that but my
father started to tell me his story over
the years
so when I came here 14 years ago and I'd
have conservatives who are born in
America said oh the commies are here
socialism has arrived I would openly
laugh at them
really communism in America let me tell
you about let me talk about the scars on
my dad's body we'll talk about communism
I don't laugh at them I don't ridicule
them anymore
when a pro-life preacher
outside of Philadelphia
who protected his 12 year old son from a
loony at an abortion crit Clinic who was
effingham-blading in his face and shoved
him away from his child
is charged with a misdemeanor assault
has that dismissed completely at a local
Court no you're protecting your child
four months later federal agents from
this city
deploy with M4 carbines in ceramic
plated hard vests at his home and arrest
him in front of his wife and seven
children
on that dismissed misdemeanor which he
finally won in court thank good Lord we
have political use of police
when a misdemeanor business misstatement
misdemeanor charged from eight years ago
which expired due to the statute of
limitations six years ago is now
magically alchemically turned into 34
felonies by a Manhattan district
attorney who received a million dollars
from George soros's funding via a cut
through NGO
after he said on his campaign for
election my number one priority is to
put president Trump in prison I don't
laugh at my fellow conservatives we have
police state tactics not far from where
we are sitting there is a jail in D.C in
the heart of DC where there are people
still in prison from the January 6 riots
didn't kill anybody didn't do anything
that goes beyond a slap on the wrist and
a fine who have yet to be arraigned
before a judge the U.S Constitution
which is based on British principles is
clear every human being has a right to
Swift Justice you must be charged within
a matter of days
to be told what your crime is they've
been in prison for two years some in
solitary without being charged that is
not a mess up it is a conscious decision
to politically use the tools of the
state so for me the the reason I am
voting for president Trump and
supporting him I need somebody to come
back into the city
and burn the corrupt
[__] to the ground
and only there's only one man in America
who cannot be re-elected if he becomes
president
there's only one man in America who's
been president once
and is running again in the Constitution
you can only have two terms they can be
separated by two terms every other
candidate from Miranda santis to Nikki
Haley would want to be re-elected after
their first term which means they're
going to behave not do anything radical
I want radical in the name
of democracy republicanism
equality before the law I want radical
changes I want Departments of this city
to be moved out DC has become 93 of DC
voted for Hillary Clinton and Biden
that's like Saddam Hussein's electoral
popularity if you are charged with a
crime in this city and you are known to
be a conservative like me you're toast
you are done the jury pool is gonna just
send you away for as long as they can
that's not right I want the CIA to be
reformed I want the FBI to be abolished
I want the Department of Education
Department of Agriculture the state Pub
to be moved to Montana to South Dakota
where patriotic Americans live and where
the permanent State bureaucrats who
think they know better than their people
will not want to live and work
we whether it's brexit whether it's Modi
whether it's uh uh Orban who I'm not a
fan of but we can talk about that
separately
um whether it's Maloney in Italy there
is an international phenomena that must
be understood it is the reassertion of
the will of the people and the elite
Must Destroy that that's why brexit was
tried how many times they tried to
annull brexit why but how dare you
choose that British people that's the
problem and and it has come to a
crescendo point where I only see one
person
who has a child and I don't even know if
you can do it
but who has a chance to somewhat bring
bring the will of the people back into
politics but Seb there are the people as
well who will say that Trump's Behavior
after he lost the election
wasn't acceptable his rhetoric was
inflammatory it was divisive
and he put American democracy in danger
yeah I I would say
um 81 million mailed out ballots and
sending the FBI to arrest uh pro-life
preachers that's the real threat to
democracy I would say having a speaker
of the house not supposed to who we've
got rid of for four years four years
openly refused to call the man elected
by 64 million Americans president she
called him the current incumbent of the
White House
that's the threat the Speaker of the
House refuses to recognize the writ of
the people the the left has become the
threat to democracy why because
everything they say about us they're
actually practicing right now they're
not far from where we're sitting uh the
homes in Virginia of the associate
Supreme Court Justices
these are the most powerful legal Minds
in the world
Democrat and Republican the Republicans
live in Virginia their houses have been
picketed since the decision on Roe v
Wade and abortion was leaked
it is a crime a federal crime in America
to pick it a judge's home because you're
exerting political pressure on somebody
who is meant to be apolitical the
department of justice under Biden
refuses to do anything about it nothing
one Airman leaks you know top secret
documents because he's flexing and you
see the footage
an FBI SWAT team in full battle rattle
in an APC
arrested the 21 year old kid
in full battle rattle
but the Supreme Court Justices Holmes we
had one Justice who was almost killed by
a pro-abortion activist traveled from
California to Virginia with a gun with a
Glock with a knife with zip ties to kill
him and his family this isn't a theory
this is a real threat so for me the left
is by far the biggest problem no but
France's point is something else which
is that uh look whatever you I didn't
think what happened on January the 6th
was a good thing I also didn't think it
was an Insurrection but if you were
designing an election from scratch
that's not how you'd want it to end up
yes I agree and and and so the the
outcome of that is that you know when we
had faraj on the show he said there are
no votes to be won on January the 6th
yeah no absolutely I I thought I mean I
was broadcasting live when Johnny six
happened and I had a former U.S attorney
in in on on air who was responsible for
securing the capital when he was the U.S
attorney and we were watching in real
time and I I admitted to myself and I
said it on air two weeks later
president Trump's political future is
it's on a threat
he he the best thing he could do is
disappear for a year and not say
anything which of course he didn't right
um
but my response is the following
even if your opinions are Justified
kind of irrelevant because you know what
I like
I like the will of the people
let all of the people decide
we have you know I have been explicit I
worked for president Trump I support
president Trump but you know what I want
a primary I don't want Rhonda Sanderson
anointed because he's not so mean on
Twitter I don't want president Trump
anointed
you don't no because I hear a lot of
people saying oh de Santa should stand
down you know he needs to get behind the
president you don't want that I I would
like if he had the balls to do it which
apparently he doesn't seem to right now
I want him on that state look that's big
let's be serious
25th I'm a political Junkie
but 2015 was epic I mean can we just
thank the good Lord for one thing Donald
Trump did apart from call out the lying
fake news media
he made politics fun again yeah how fun
was politics I would like to see not 17
people on the stage let's have you know
27 people and the toughest guy or gal
you know duking it out is the last
person standing and I've said from the
beginning you know there's a I'm an
immigrant to America but I've heard of
this thing called primaries let's have
him anybody who wants to run Vivek I
love Vivek Rama Swami super smart guy
I'd love to see Vivek I told him on my
show I would like you to be the Jared
Kushner of the next Trump administrator
I want you to be the you know the
business Innovation forward-thinking
Cabinet member I don't think he's got a
shot at presidency but you're a smart
guy come on in join the club but I'd
love to see one of the base stage you
know test my boss come up with some you
know creative
combinations of ideas but no I I to your
point yeah whatever happened on Johnny 6
and however the president responded
afterwards which was sub-optimal let's
put it diplomatically
okay he's declared
so let the people decide oh sure yeah
completely yeah right so with that in
mind primaries competition which I like
that you said that because that's how I
feel about democracy I don't understand
why people wouldn't want certain
candidates to run
what's wrong with the santis
um so he's done a great job in Florida
yes but why
why
everybody loves Austin Powers right
because we're on the scientist is the
Mini-Me of President Trump
what he's doing in Florida is like a
scaled down version of America first but
applied to one state so you know as Bill
Maher said recently
why would you go to the tribute bands
concert if the OG band is still playing
good point why would you vote for the
Mini-Me version who can kind of do stuff
at that level on the state who has no
background in foreign policy no no chops
on Nash security why would you it's a
pig in a poke it's you know you don't
know so let me let's firstly I want him
on the
platform I want him on the primary but
here are the problems with Ron
my buddy who has the morning show here
on radio who is my show prep keeps
millions of people sane he was talking
about Rhonda stantis running for
governor way back when whatever it was
three years ago and he said this
three-term congressman from Florida
and I we help each other right and I was
just about to text him live on air and
say Chris
what are you talking about
three-term Congressman you've got to
have your fact checkers do their work
and then I I thought okay before I press
send
I'm going to Google his CV
oh yeah Chris was right he'd served five
and a half years in Congress
and me a political junkie had no idea if
you've been in Congress for three terms
and I haven't heard your name
odds are you're probably an oxygen Thief
secondly a couple of issues
that really disturb me one of his
biggest backers now is Ken Griffin Ken
Griffin is a billionaire
uh hedge fund Tech guy or what have you
who is a never Trumper who was Obama's
biggest bundler
excuse me
why is Obama's
if you're conservative biggest campaign
funding bundler
one of the biggest
people funding somebody who's supposed
to be the new Donald Trump my fear is
that they are Whispering sweet nothings
in his ear saying you're the guy you're
the guy and he's being exploited by The
Establishment Rhino class the
Republicans in name only and I've looked
in the camera on my shirt I said Ron Ron
for president good on you don't let
yourself become a tool of the
establishment that hates populist Maga
America first whatever you want to call
it the last thing is where this is where
he tanked in the last few weeks his
flip-flop on Ukraine desire this is the
guy who has to prove most that he's good
on foreign policy as a former Navy
officer his flip-flop on Ukraine within
72 hours was a disaster and it showed in
the polls and then most telling of all
is his response to the leak of the
indictment against President Trump
his first press conference on the Monday
after was leaked on Saturday was
catastrophic a he decided not to talk
about it
despite the fact that President Trump
lives in the state he is the governor of
in Florida
then in the Q a on some thing about tech
a journalist naturally said could you
react to the leaked indictment of
President Trump and twice not once twice
like a churlished little punk in the
schoolyard he mentions well I'm not
going to comment on uh hush money for
porn stars grow up Ron
if you're a conservative you believe in
Law and Order and that lady Justice is
blindfolded so you're going to make fun
I know you know it's kind of fun to dig
and say hush money for porn stars but
not only are you the governor of the
state in which the citizen resides who
should have equality before the law
whether he's a former president or not
secondly and you have to know his
background he was a Jag
he was a member of the Judge Advocate
General Corps for the Navy which means
he was a prosecutor he was a lawyer if
anyone should have something to say
about politically aggressive prosecutors
doing things that are shady it should
probably be a former military prosecutor
and he paid the price and in the
policies between 20 to 40 points behind
president Trump
um but good luck to him but you know not
impressive so far in in these issues
president Trump and Ukraine
do you think he stands a chance no
nobody look Kissinger not a big fan of
trump although he used to hang out in
the White House almost every weekend he
loved to be back in the halls of power
when we were there
Kissinger has said and he's been around
I mean he's been around as well he said
he hasn't seen anybody mobilize
Americans like President Trump does
since FDR
when Kissinger says the power of this
man to mobilize Americans
it hasn't been seen since Roosevelt
you probably should pay attention and
let's just be empirical one of the
funniest things about the campaign in 15
because I'd be advising president Trump
on National Security is I'd go to Trump
town to The Campaign Headquarters with
with some regularity and I'd be in there
constantly overhearing the conversations
of yeah we booked Mr Trump for this High
School stadium but it's already
overflowing we've got to go to the the
next one get the local State football
that the the popular they were
constantly having to cancel engagements
and go to bigger venues because this is
the only man in America who can announce
tomorrow I'm going to Miami or
Poughkeepsie or anywhere and fill a
stadium with 60 000 people Biden could
get six Ron maybe 10. this man anywhere
even in Democrat States
so can get the people I flew with him on
Air Force One to Youngstown Ohio
Youngstown is the Rust Belt okay it's
it's the part of America that's been
destroyed
we were riding in the Convoy to the
stadium and on the left all you saw was
disused empty shattered steel mills on
the right families dressed very modestly
standing on on the pavement waving their
stars and stripes we got to the stadium
boss was in the back glad handing with
with the you know VIPs I decided to go
into the pit of the stadium and meet
with the people of Youngstown and your
selfies and all that jazz
when President Trump and Melania came
out on stage
it was electric he couldn't start his
speech because for minutes the crowd
spontaneously were chanting USA USA USA
this
in a town
that is 90 Democrat the people in that
Stadium were Democrats the dads were
Democrats their granddads were Democrats
that's a force of nature whether you
like his tweets or not the fact that
working class Americans
who have been betrayed by the UNA party
for 60 years
look at this billionaire as a guy who
cares
it's a it's an Unstoppable force of
nature
so the difficulty is and I'm not even
Playing devil's advocate here which is
kind of my job but actually this is what
I genuinely a question in my mind is
there are two elements to winning an
election one is what you're talking
about which is mobilizing right right
the other one is persuading the
undecided correct
and that is undoubtedly
the problem with president Trump's
approach right now he you made the point
yourself and you articulated very well
at the last election he mobilized more
of his base than any incumbent president
in history
but at the same time he still lost and
his ability to persuade is is extremely
limited now I think because of his
rhetoric but also January the 6th and
also the indictment right the people who
are the undecided they're going to be
harder to win over for him and the
reason people are talking about DeSantis
is that
they see him as very competent in terms
of the things he did particularly covet
I think that was a big deal for a lot of
people right the things that he's done
there and and many other other things
that he's doing in Florida and on top of
that because he does not have uh you're
right he doesn't animate people in the
same way but animation can go in both
directions so he doesn't off put as many
people or put off as many people as
president Trump does and that's why I
think a lot of people on your side are
saying well maybe if we just get this
guy who I agree with you he he he is in
some ways uh taking on a lot of the the
you know the the the gestures of
President Trump and the the finger and
well making fun of the press and
everything right right but he isn't
going to have the toxicity and as a
result he is a better candidate to
actually try to heal some of the divides
in this country that's the argument I I
so you know to be the bastard or to
sound like trans Pitbull I'm not
interested in healing divides I want to
save the nation
it's a difference between in military
terms uh there there's a tank five
clicks away Over the Horizon that can
blow me to Smithereens but there's a guy
in front of me with a gun with a Bayonet
and he's about to put it put it in my
guts
the situation in America right now is
there's a guy with a Bayonet coming for
me uh two feet away when the FBI is
doing what they're doing when when
parents are being targeted by the
Department of Justice because they dare
to say we don't want
Peter Phillip pornography in the school
library we don't want uh racist Concepts
like critical racer to be taught to 10
year olds and we want our kids back in
school without masks and the FBI is
actually created a threat tag it's
getting technical but they created a
whole terminology to use Patriot act
counter-terrorism tools to Target
parents and now we know Catholics a
recent memo was leaked from Richmond FBI
headquarters FBI a field office saying
watch out and make sure you surveil
Catholics who go to traditional masses
especially Latin Masses as potential
threats to America
not BLM
not antifa Catholics there has been no
attack that I know of since I've lived
in America that was because of people
who went to Latin mass as Catholics
the bayonet is inching towards the
sternum of this nation
I'm not we can heal after we stop the
corruption in this city the political
weaponization of the most powerful
government in in the world must be
stopped and I'm sorry Ron DeSantis
doesn't have the balls or the maturity
to do it and there's one man who's lived
walked through the the arena for four
years six years now
who
[Music]
is has more potential than anyone to fix
it and to your point about winning there
is a very I mean we're all political
junkies there's a very disturbing fact
in American politics uh between 20 and
32 percent of the electorate decide who
they're going to vote on in a
presidential election in the last eight
days which blows my mind I mean you're
in a tribe yes you are in a tribe you're
in a tribe as well as I am we we love
the west but the idea that you could you
could go from you know Jimmy Carter to
Reagan in the last week before an
election like kind of flip a coin he's
like what
my contention my hope I can't prove it
is that things will be so so bad
in 20 months time
that the undecideds the middle of the
road will vote for president Trump not
because he's magger or because he's
going to drain the Deep state but
because
I mean I don't know if you follow this
in England
recently
we didn't have baby formula in America
we had a baby formula drought you went
to the local you know Safeway and the
Shelf was empty
this is the only nation on God's green
earth that put 12 men on the moon
we went there six times but we don't
have baby formula
we had a disastrous train accident
chemical waste Inferno
it took the government
14 days to go to the site of the
disaster as if the people in this Trump
working-class District
didn't really matter
if you look at inflation
if you look at the incapacity of kids to
buy property and start on the the ladder
it's going to get worse so my hope is
it's not cool campaign ads or polite
tweets that are going to save us
it's going to be that so many people are
going to say I'm sorry the pendulum has
to swing back
we'll find out if that happens we will
one last question before we go let's
talk about your political hero Joe Biden
Beijing Biden yeah
is he going to run again uh he thinks he
is and Jill you can Jill is voted on
that one already
um I I cannot believe the DNC the
Democratic National Convention will
allow him to
um
how do you stop a man who is the
president
from running is a tough question
so you indict him
so I'm approaching your question with
logic so the left is no longer driven by
Logic
I I cannot predict for you what an
irrational entity will do he's running
his wife thinks he's running uh the DNC
um
look to be throwing him under the bus
continually the whole classified
document thing that didn't come from the
right I I have utter certitude that the
whole you know secret documents in his
garage in his office that was from
somebody on the inside who wanted to get
rid of him uh can I get rid of him no
idea
but he thinks he's running
so there we go Seb what a pleasure thank
you so much thank you guys for coming on
the show if people want to buy your
books if people want to find you online
where's the best way to do that yeah so
I'm everywhere except uh the fascist of
YouTube so you can find me on
sebgorker.com Sebastian gorka.com
Twitter Facebook Instagram said Goku
Sebastian Gorka and of course my sub
stack that I promise I will write more
frequently that's
sebastian.substack.com the latest book
is the war for America's Soul so you can
find me anywhere daily radio show you
can listen to uh on you know your iTunes
Apple podcast is America first and then
I have a TV show on Newsmax as well and
so before we let you go and not only let
you go but before we go to locals where
people have submitted their questions uh
that only they will get to see the
answers to uh as always what's the one
thing we're not talking about that we
really should be well I'm gonna give you
two generous I know I know you're in
America but we do things bigger here
number one and you might take Umbridge
here
it's the transgender thing
but one aspect of it the idea that
doctors who've taken the Hippocratic
Oath are mutilating miners
is the essence of evil we I don't want
to talk about transgenderism in general
but doctor medical professionals harming
children in many cases autistic children
must be stopped and these people must be
punished and put in prison
the second one is a philosophical one
and it came to me in the depths of covid
cowardice
this nation was was built
on rugged individuals in the Pioneer
spirit
you you drove with me through the Deep
Countryside of West Virginia you saw the
Spirit of these are people that you know
Sally fourth young man Into the
Wilderness and create
the idea that a nation that was founded
and celebrates
that myth that narrative
of fortitude of Courage
was shut down
by the likes of fauci
Beggar's belief
the idea that we were told
that for a disease that has really only
uh a Threat Level applicable to those
with serious comorbidities or certain
age cohort
we were taught to shut down all business
unless your Walmart or Amazon you will
shut down the fact that only you know
this restaurant owner in California this
gym owner in New York said screw you I
get to feed my family and my employees
get to feed their kids the fact that it
wasn't tens of thousands of Americans
have said no I will assume the risk it
is my decision it is my employees
decision the fact that we genuflected at
the altar of fouchy and fear for me is
what we have we have to find fortitude
and courage again and and this isn't an
American thing this is a western
civilization thing you know this from
your industry why is your industry dead
why is comedy dead
cowardice that's what it is so we need
to talk about
what it means
to have courage and give I'll give you
one story and then we can move to locals
before the election I was invited with
my wife to speak at a at a concerted
event
at the Trump Golf Course here
and it was a Gala so you know black tie
and I arrived early my wife was going to
speak I was going to speak we arrived to
the ballroom this woman sees me from
across the ballroom rushes over to me in
a lovely ball gown and says Dr G Dr G
can I get a selfie and I said of course
take the selfie and afterwards I said to
her what I said to everyone that takes a
selfie with me
don't forget to tag me when you post it
suddenly her Visage changed she got all
Doer and she said uh oh I I can't put it
on Facebook I I can't post it
my husband he's self-employed and and
this part of Northern Virginia is so
Democrat when
at that moment a little part of me died
an hour later when I was asked to stand
up in front of you know 400 Patriots to
make a speech I talked about this woman
she was there I didn't use her name but
I said the following
if you
do not put your name
to the values you say you hold you do
not hold those values
and you don't deserve or have the right
to describe yourself based upon those
adjectives
it's a very simple calculation you can't
say I'm a patriot I love America I'm a
conservative or I'm a I love the working
class and I'm a labor voter if you
aren't able to actually associate you
with those values so man up
and live your values
a woman up
uh if you must
Dr Sebastian Gorka thank you so much for
being back on the show and thank you for
what you do I told you guys privately
you guys are unique you are providing a
service nobody else is doing and there's
a reason I've said publicly on numerous
occasions the best podcast
outside of America is trigonometry so I
salute you guys thank you so much thank
you so much uh join us on locals where
we're going to ask Seb your questions uh
thank you for being here for watching
this we've got more amazing interviews
coming from our American trip and more
so take care and we'll see you on locals
very shortly take care and see you soon
guys
because this isn't YouTube we can talk
about this Sean G says seeing as Trump
reckons the last election was rigged
thank you
foreign
[Music]